every year an estimated one in five
American adults experiences mental
illness so when it comes to insurance
coverage the law is clear on this the
federal mental health parity legislation
passed back in 2008 requires health
insurers to provide at least equal
coverage for mental health conditions as
they do for medical and surgical care
but as our doc dr. Jon LaPook his name
does not change reports some families
still have to fight to get the
life-saving care their loved ones really
need you can see and just looking at how
close they were they were very very
close they did everything together which
is very troubling when Nicole passed in
2013
Brian quedas 15 year old daughter took
her own life a year and a half later his
younger daughter attempted suicide she
was unable to really process the death
of her sister she kept it inside
residential treatment was denied a less
intensive level of care was approved the
hospital said what that translates to is
your daughter has not failed often
enough to get a longer term treatment
center so she has to have attempted
suicide several times each time rolling
the dice it might actually succeed
that's correct
after a second suicide attempt she was
approved for residential care after
three weeks there the clinical staff
described an increase in suicidal
ideation and that she clearly met
criteria to continue treatment there but
just days later the insurer united
behavioral health part of united health
group wrote the services asked for are
not medically needed they were basically
protecting their profitability Kato
could only afford another three weeks it
takes time and because she didn't have
that time she went back into a
withdrawal situation
my son was homeless three different
times because he was discharged from the
hospital and there was no program for
him to go into Sylvia ta's has kept a
meticulous record of her son's mental
illnesses and her efforts to get his
treatments covered nine to ten times
you're getting denied the kind of care
that you know your loved one requires he
has schizoaffective disorder diagnosed
in his teen
and has been hospitalized more than a
dozen times this is one of the more
historic farms he now works with TAWS
and her husband on the family's organic
farm they have depleted their retirement
savings paying for his mental health
care Todd's played us this 2016
voicemail from a care coordinator
discussing how many more days would be
covered at a residential care facility
just if his symptoms have worsened
they're letting you know the only chance
of greater care is if your child's
symptoms get worse and then you end up
where you're oddly slightly hoping that
something worsens another thing is maybe
getting Medicaid for you
you hear the suggestion that your son
get Medicaid yes from the United
healthcare people yep
and why should this be slept off to
taxpayers there shouldn't be the
lobbying it should be there's a
diagnosis this requires long-term care a
class-action lawsuit claimed patients
were illegally denied benefits based on
United behavioral health internal
guidelines attorney Mayor Rahm Ben dot
is co-counsel for the plaintiffs oh
you're the managed care reviewer and I'm
the patient or the provider I could
protest all I want and you could always
hold up your guidelines and say look you
just don't meet these criteria but what
if the criteria themselves are just
flagrantly off-base and you think they
are well I I don't think so the court
thought so earlier this year the federal
court ruled against ubh and called the
guidelines flawed unreasonable and more
restrictive than generally accepted
standards of care and that financial
incentives infected the guideline
development process and there's
thousands of families in our situation
and they eventually give up there's no
more money to fund care ta's says her
son is now stable and living with them
Katie's daughter left that residential
facility in 2017 and now they have very
little contact it's my belief that she
blames me for the loss of her sister
where does that leave you it leaves me
that with the sensation that I have
really lost both daughters the United
behavioral health told CBS News we want
our members to have the mental health
support they need when they need it the
company says it is revising guidelines
to be more in line with the way
practicing clinicians actually determine
the level of care a patient needs I
don't even know what to say about this
it's jaw-dropping and heartbreaking at
the same time you did the story I
thought your head was gonna pop off
listening to this because it makes no
sense
so so what does this say about how we
view mental health you're right about
the head popping off yeah infuriate and
what it says is that we have to
understand that mental health problems
their medical problems can you imagine
an insurance company saying to a doctor
whose patient has diabetes you know we
don't think that your patient needs
insulin right this is what we think I
mean we there's a federal law that
protects these patients they have to
have parity they have to treat just like
any other medical problems we have to
start figuring that out we have to start
following through and covering people
with mental health problems that is just
one of the reasons why we're talking
about it because that stigma it really
is alive and well thank you Jon LaPook
of course we'll see you tomorrow Jon
LaPook we'll share more about getting
help for mental health challenges
tomorrow
and our live special we've been telling
you about it all week really hope you'll
watch we're calling it stop the stigma a
conversation about mental health again
that's tomorrow live right here on CBS
this morning